With regard to general Flynn and his unmasking.
I think it goes at least up to Joe Biden, Joe Biden.
We now have documents that were declassified yesterday by Rick Grinnell that
show the Joe Biden requested the unmasking of general Flynn.
I'm Dave Rubin. And this is the Rubin report. Quick reminder,
everybody to subscribe to our channel and click that little bell.
So you get delivered our videos. And more importantly,
joining me today is the junior Senator from Kentucky and the fiercest defender
of Liberty that we have in the United States government, Senator Rand, Paul,
I'm thrilled. You're finally joining us today, be on your show.
All right, so let's dive in. I think we're just going to split this interview.
I know you've got about a half hour.
We're going to just split it into two parts.
Let's spend the first half talking about this Pfizer amendment, uh,
that you just proposed. Uh, can you just talk a little bit about why you did it,
what's going on with surveillance?
I sense people are seriously confused about the whole Flynn case,
what the Obama administration may or may not have known.
So if you could just kind of do a one Oh one to clean up some of that,
that would be great.
The Pfizer court is the foreign intelligence surveillance court,
and it was set up in the seventies basically to investigate spy
on surveil foreigners and possible terrorists. Um,
it was never intended really to be used against political candidate candidates
or to investigate American political campaigns or American political figures.
But as everybody know,
this is what the secret court that they used to go after president Trump in
2016 in the summer and the fall. And, uh,
I think this was a horrendous abuse of power and using a secret court to go
after an American, I think is a, is a travesty of justice.
So this is a court that lacks, uh, constitutional protections.
When you go to a regular court,
a constitutional court that was established by article three of the
constitution, you get a lawyer, that's one obvious thing you get,
but you also get the fourth amendment.
The fourth amendment says that they can't search your house or your phone or any
of these things unless they go to a judge and they have to say that there's
probable cause that you committed a crime. It's a, it's a fairly high standard,
but it's the constitutional standard in the visor court.
They go to it and they say, well,
you just have to have probable cause that we think you are associated with a
foreign government. So that's what they do at Carter page. They said, Oh,
we see you've talked to the Russians. And he said, well, yeah, I told the CIA,
you know, I run into Russians. I do business I'm in these think tanks. And I,
I told the CIA and they know that I've talked to the Russians before and I've
tried to give them information. They discounted all that lied with the court.
And then what began this whole Trump investigation. But here's my point.
A lot of Republicans, a lot of conservatives, a lot of libertarians are upset.
How do you fix it?
One way of it is to try to make the Pfizer court system more like
a constitutional court. So add protections in the scheme of things.
But here's my point. I don't think it's possible to make it constitutional.
They don't notify you that they're investigating you. So it's secret.
You don't get a lawyer.
Some of the reforms are to give you a friend Amaka so somebody,
a friend of the court that argues three, but they still don't tell you,
you have been accused of anything.
So you don't really direct a lawyer to direct your defense.
And so I don't think it fixes a system. So my amendment would simply say this,
the visor court really isn't constitutional for Americans.
So let's exempt Americans from it and let's use it only on foreigners. It is,
you know, for all, it's called the foreign intelligence court.
Why don't we go after foreigners with it? And people said, well, what if,
what if there really was a spine and political campaign? What would you do?
Well, use the constitution, go to a judge, ask for, uh,
a warrant to search the person or to surveil the person and judges do grab
things like that. But you have to have evidence,
but you'd also have to UMaine the bill of rights in the fourth amendment.
That's where I'm for. But unfortunately I'm in the minority up here.
I think that would win with your crowd watching, but I'm afraid it probably,
it didn't have enough votes in the Senate to win. Yeah.
Yeah. Well, I assure you,
you're doing just fine in the majority on my audience and we've got some work to
do there. So can you just clarify a little bit, it seems that sort of right.
Leaning Twitter,
let's call it right now is saying that this stuff really went up the chain of
command and it's possible now that Biden and or Obama themselves actually knew
about it and were, were instigating some of this stuff.
What's the actual evidence at this point?
Well, with regard to general Flynn and his unmasking,
I think it goes at least up to Joe Biden, Joe Biden.
We now have documents that were declassified yesterday by Rick Grinnell,
that show that Joe Biden requested the unmasking of general Flynn.
What does that mean?
They get like a national security or a fossa warrant to listen to the phone
call of the Russian ambassador.
I can kind of understand that we spot ambassadors based by an next week.
It goes on around the world.
But if that ambassador is talking to a person who's elected to our government or
part of the administration like general Flynn, they're supposed to say, Oh no,
he's talking to an American. We're not supposed to listen. Or if we listen,
we're not supposed to unmask that person. Well, the thing is,
if you're a prominent person, a lot of people know you by your voice.
And you may well introduce yourself by saying Mr. Ambassador,
this is general Flynn. So it's kind of,
it's hard to really completely mask it, but here's the point.
You're only supposed to unmask that person if there's a national security
reason. So if they're plotting to attack the us, you would say, well,
that's reasonable. You unmask them to try to stop the plot.
But if they're discussing policy and the person's,
the national security advisor,
there would be absolutely no reason other than a politically motivated one.
So if this is politically motivated, then it becomes illegal surveillance,
illegal eavesdropping. And really, you remember,
we have this impeachment trial over them saying someone in government used
government to go after a political opponent,
turns out what they did to general Flynn sounds exactly like that.
They abused government.
They use surveillance to go after their political opponent.
Are you worried for, for a limited government guy?
You don't want the administrative state to be too big.
It's like you can get in the weeds on all of this stuff, but in many ways,
this is what you've spent your whole life fighting.
That peop that the whole system has just gotten so big and crazy at this point.
That even if you tell people what's true and we have all the facts in front of
us, that sort of the ship has sailed on,
on reigning in the things that I think you and I,
and most of my audience are worried.
Yes and no. Um, I think if you were asking your audience,
obviously it's probably a very limited government audience,
but even if we were asking a general audience. So for example,
if I asked everybody in Kentucky about whether or not a secret court where you
don't get a lawyer should investigate political campaigns,
other that polls at 75%, particularly to keep Trump out of it.
Now Trump's pretty popular my stage. So it doesn't hurt so much,
but really if you could get Trump out of it, but the problem is people get,
they won't vote on principle and idea.
So I didn't get any Democrat votes on this and only got 11 Republicans,
but I got no Democrats, even though many of them profess to, uh,
think that Pfizer has too much power and shouldn't be investigating Americans,
they wouldn't vote for it because they saw it as a vote rebuking visa over
Trump. And so they saw it as a political vote.
But I guess I don't look at it this way.
I lose a lot of time and I'm I'm and I'm used to losing and votes in the
Senate.
And I think most of this in this is where we do have some ability.
So we pass out a sheet of a prominent tweets that went out from
senators each, each week on Wednesday. And all my office does this sheet.
And they all complained because we'll put out something in my tweet will have
gotten 30,000 retweets and they will put out Senator so-and-so and they got six.
So one of the things they see is that the Liberty movement has
reach well beyond them. And they fear the electric.
These people are afraid of elections. They're afraid of me.
They're afraid of conservatives because they're afraid someday someone's going
to wake up and challenge them in the primary. And that's what has to happen. Um,
the Democrats,
it's sort of like this Democrats don't care at all about the deficit and they'll
tell you, and they want to spend more money. They're honest about it.
Republicans say they're against debt, say they're against spending,
but they're also most of them,
big government Republicans vote lockstep with the Democrats.
So really when people ask me whose fault is it Republican or Democrat? I say,
yeah, you know what? It's really party's fault,
but you know, we could give up and just try to protect ourselves. But, you know,
I think if we give up and the view, good voices year, go away, then really,
I think it goes much quicker towards socialism.
It goes much quicker towards indebtedness and big government.
So I have to be some voices. There needs to be more,
the newer people up here I think are frankly better than, um, you know,
the ones that have been here a long time. So I have good conversations with, uh,
Senator Braun, uh,
Senator Rick Scott from Florida and who I think are open to as, you know,
an ISO amendment,
Mike Lee, or with me on the Pfizer amendment. Also.
Can you talk a little bit about your relationship with Trump?
Because one of the things that I've said to my audience repeatedly is first off,
I should tell you, you'll appreciate this. I voted for Gary Johnson,
I'm here in California. And I had the luxury of, you know,
doing a third-party situation, which obviously certain people,
depending on where you live, you didn't have the luxury of doing that. Um,
but I wanted to make a vote for Liberty more than anything else,
but one of the reasons that I've become more okay with Trump over the last
couple of years is that the guy that I respect most in the Senate,
you has become one of his big allies. And my feeling was well, if Ron Paul,
who I aligned with on so much of the Liberty stuff,
sees something in him that he can work with. Then I view that as a net. Good.
Can you talk about a little bit about your relationship personally,
but also just what do you think his actual governing principles are?
Cause it's hard to say they're traditionally conservative or Republican or
whatever else.
He doesn't come from a steep, uh,
developed or possibly of libertarianism.
However, when you talk to him about warm and he talks about the Iraq war,
he gets it more than any other Republican,
obviously other than my dad or myself or Mike Lee.
Gets it.
If you're looking for more honest and thoughtful conversations about politics,
instead of nonstop yelling, checkout our politics playlist.
And if you want to watch full interviews on a variety of topics,
watch our full episode playlist, all right, over here,
and to get notified of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and click the notification bell.